Speaker 1: . A Donald Trump's lawyer, Christina
Bobb, is lawyering up and willing to cooperate
with the Department of Justice. My how
quickly things change when you are one of
Donald Trump's lawyers remember MAGA really
means making attorneys get attorneys. Salon
reports Trump attorney lawyers up and says she's
willing to cooperate with the DOJ in Mar a Lago
case. At least one member of former President
Trump's legal team has hired her own lawyer,
and allies are urging another to follow
suit. Trump attorney Christina Bobb and
Trump attorney Evan Corcoran affirm to the
Justice Department that Trump did hand over
all those classified records from Mar a Lago.
But prosecutors say that that wasn't true.
The response was incomplete after the FBI searched
and found more documents. Bobb, who, by the way,
is also an anchor on right side broadcasting, if
you can imagine the incestuous nature of what's
going on there. Bob has since hired her own lawyer
and made it known to Trump allies she is willing
to cooperate and be interviewed by the Justice
Department. Colleagues have also urged Corcoran
to hire a criminal defense lawyer because of his
response to the subpoena. According to the report,
he insists it's not necessary. Bob told The
Washington Post when asked whether she was
negotiating for a sit down interview with the DOJ.
I'm sorry, I'm not allowed to talk about it. Now,
remember, Bob's relevance in this entire
thing that is in this article where it says,
quote, Bob signed a document affirming that
Trump handed over all the documents that are
responsive to the subpoena. After a diligent
search, Corcoran then met with DOJ officials
and made a similar statement. They then
found that that was not actually true.
Now, another important aspect of this is that
Bob helped push Trump's legal challenges after
the election and has insisted that she believes
the document she signed was accurate. But she
also told Right Side Broadcasting she's not
actually acting as Trump's attorney while
serving as a custodian of records. She's only
doing the custodian of records thing. So listen,
here's the bottom line on this. Even if you are
a Trump supporter, how can you justify him taking
the documents? What is your explanation for what
he was planning to do with them and why did he lie
about them having been returned? Did he not know?
And you believe, Christina, Bob is the one who
lied while Christina Bob says she signed off on it
because she believed the documents were returned.
So who told her? Because if it's not Trump who
said lie and say the documents were returned
and if Christina Bob was just doing what she was
told, who came up with we are going to claim the
documents were returned. The next part of it is,
are any of the explanations that anybody has given
believable? Right. The documents were for Trump's
library that he doesn't care about. The documents
were for Trump to write his memoirs, even though
Trump doesn't write. The documents were for Trump
to read, even though Trump doesn't read. The
documents were declassified telepathically
right before the FBI planted them. None of the
stories make sense, and what we're learning is
every single one of these people is in over their
heads. Think about the number of red flags here.
And what it sounds like is that Christina Bob
realized people are going down. This is a very
serious criminal investigation. The FBI knows that
we didn't really return the documents. And my name
is they're saying the documents were returned
and she is now trying to distance herself. But
the theme is being Trump's lawyer really doesn't
go well. It often doesn't go well financially,
although Trump's Louis newest lawyers are.
Collecting money upfront, which is smart of them
to do, and it often doesn't go well criminally or
in terms of your legal career either. Christina
Bobb has lawyered up. Who will be next? Find
me on Twitter at D Pacman and let me know